[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur la route des
fleurs à sainte-marie direction piton
fougères
moi j'ai été dans la brigade
anti-terroriste franco-allemande en
allemagne en 2000 2001 j'étais pilote
bbl grenadiers voltigeurs est aussi
charger un musicien s'est ensuite j'ai
préparé un bp rea niveau 4 pour être
chef d'exploitation agricole aujourd'hui
je suis agriculteur dans les
hauts-de-seine mari je suis tombé dedans
quand j'étais petit parce que ma mère
elle faisait que ça donc je la suivais
en livraison même pendant sa production
jeu les aider à planter à ramasser à
l'évent normale et j'ai appris sur le
tard et aujourd'hui j'ai quand même
acquérir une grande expérience grâce à
ma mère
j'ai trois mille mètres carrés de serres
qui doit être rénové impérativement de
soi cette année sans fin d'année ou
l'année prochaine
ici je cultive des plantes des plantes
fleuries des plantes de jardin des
plantes d'intérieur je suis principal
principalement producteurs de muguet ça
c'est ma production je produis des
hortensias par toute l'année et davis
pendant toute l'année
- 12 variétés glisse délice parfumé et
des listes non parfumé je travaille moi
même je suis libéral dans l'avenir je
compte embaucher un à trois ouvriers
pour vos projets d'installation alors je
plante je vends quand je vais planter
les bulbes gelé décongèle deux jours à
l'avance je trie et les buts j'en ai pas
mal de variété que je vend à l'unité
gd des compliments des clients par
exemple sur la préparation de la terre
que je fais ça booste en feuilles à
anvers dur et aussi en fleurs donc les
gens ils sont satisfaits du résultat
ma performance dans ce contexte covic et
de ne pas abandonner de persévérer de
produire en maximum de qualité pour
satisfaire la clientèle
il faut pas abandonner il faut donner le
paquet il faut faire vivre sa famille
moi je dis et pour faire vivre sa
famille il suffit de travailler pas
capable est mort sans essayer
[Musique]
bienvenue à la possession chez adobe
il est toujours été un passionné de
technologie j'ai fait des études en
micro technologies que j'étais
responsable de bureau d'études ont des
goûts
l'entreprise assez importante en
métropole pendant plus de dix ans nous
avons décidé avec ma femme de venir
vivre à la réunion
étant donné que ma famille réunionnaise
j'ai dû trouver un nouveau métier donc
je suis devenu responsable
d'exploitation en métallerie en solo des
en tôlerie sortie des études je voulais
déjà créé une entreprise et j'ai senti
que c'était le moment j'ai été
accompagné à près par la bce
initiative réunion à la chambre des
métiers à celle expertise qui est un
cabinet d'experts comptables et mois et
des mois accompagné monde il n'est pas
peur et tu vas pour aller voir les
banques présentes et on projette tu sais
ce que tu veux
ici nous sommes dans la partie atelier
métallerie chaudronnerie ou on façonne
les projets de nos clients et nous avons
pendant cette période de confinement
développer un système de nettoyant pour
les mains de sans contact l'achat box
elle a été conçue dans nos bureaux
d'études à l'aide de nos logiciels de 3d
de conception donc aujourd'hui avec
notre ferme d'imprimantes 3d on peut
réaliser en série le 200 500 caisses en
plastique avec une flexibilité vraiment
exceptionnel avec des outils innovants
qu'est la 3d
les logiciels de simulation numérique on
va pouvoir prototype et mais très
rapidement parce qu'on a notre propre
outil de production et les accompagner à
prévert de l'industrialisation et s'y
trouver des solutions pour concevoir des
produits qui sont aujourd'hui importés
mais qu'on peut fabriquer ici
vraiment on est parti avec une petite
équipe de deux métallier deux emplois et
un an après on est déjà six
collaborateurs
on a fait 30 % de plus par rapport à
notre chiffre sachant qu'il ya eu un
mois de creux par rapport à la coved
traduire les demandes de nos clients au
point de vue technique et pouvoir
directement par ma propre usine les
fabriquer donc ce qui permet d'être très
réactif d'être très flexible et d'être
très performant sur le respect des
délais la qualité je remercie vraiment
toute mon équipe d'être avec moi dans ce
projet
steiner on a un proverbe l'imagination
est plus importante que le savoir la
finale du challenge des créateurs aient
lieu à l'hémicycle du département
c'est là que frédéric neyrat samu de
l'entreprise du même nom remporte la
catégorie performance
[Musique]